[Music]
hmm welcome to the lecture all right man
this is my first time trying the YouTube
livestream testing testing testing
testing it's early on a Sunday though
not that early man and it's way too
early to find out that Kenny Rogers has
passed away what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
man how do we lose Kenny like I know
people get old and people have to die
man
I get it I've been here long enough I'm
49 I lost a lot of people but you know
Kenny Rogers man come on we're talking
about the soundtrack of my childhood
when I was a kid my mom on Sunday
mornings you know we'd go to church and
then afterwards we'd come home and my
mom would make like a brunch or you know
we didn't call it that that was fancy
we've had breakfast after church and we
had like we had a small screened-in like
front porch at our house so my mom would
like we're all eating on the porch like
every once in a while she'd feel like
family and stuff like that
and we'd go out on the porch and my mom
made eggs scrambled eggs we were poor we
grew up lower lower lower lower lower
lower lower middle class and so the egg
scrambled eggs weren't just eggs it was
like eggs with milk in them to make more
and then anything my mother found she
put into the eggs so like [ __ ] bacon
bits going to the eggs vanilla extract
tube goes into the
poppy seeds like whatever the [ __ ] she
just put it on to the eggs and then we
go out on the on the porch and me my dad
my mom my brother and sister would sit
there and eat our eggs like we were a
rich family but we were not and so while
that was happening Kenny
playing on the on the Wi-Fi in the
background man my mom and dad had like
you know like would they call it then
she would always say I don't know I
forget what it was called but it was
like a record player when it was a hi-fi
system essentially but it looked like a
piece of furniture you know and I had to
get dusted every weekend cuz I had to
dust it so she'd put on like the best
Kenny Rogers album and that would play
all morning long and my parents would
sing and they were not like singers they
were not you know I'm me and my kid and
you know I'm artsy Lord I try to be in
[ __ ] like that so if I was sitting
around singing making breakfast like it
kind of makes sense my parents were not
those people at all and so when you
heard him saying when they burst in song
it was I know it was incredibly special
because you know they sang in church
because they were forced to you know the
funeral dirge type song oh god please
don't kill us this week Alleluia hope
you're there
so we'd sing in church but you know that
was you had to if you didn't they looked
at you other people on the church from
the pews lugia like don't you love Jesus
[ __ ] sing so when my parents would
burst into like [ __ ] song like
listening to Kenny Rogers it was pretty
magical man because you were seeing a
version of them that he never got see
particularly may like the youthful
joyful version of them you know like
kids kids sing teenagers [ __ ] sing
people in their 20s hoping to go out and
if I can hook up I imagine sing but you
know parents in the 70s and 80s
and really sing so when my parents you
know [ __ ] like my mom dad bullet my
dad was the real Mindbender exceed
barely even [ __ ] spoke my sister says
I stole Silent Bob from him cuz he never
said anything until he had something
important to say and then it was usually
kind of biting so he was always [ __ ]
quiet man who but you know his like I
remember he would go into his room on
the weekends and he had like a record
player in his room and stuff another
like hi-5 system which sounds like we
were rich but no we weren't these were
old [ __ ] busted ass record players
and [ __ ] and so he'd go in there and
he'd put on he loved country music so
he'd put on like Hank Williams and [ __ ]
and just croon at the top of his lungs
man my old man was saying it was such a
foreign notion to me like he can sing he
knows I was saying what the [ __ ] that
all about and same thing with Kenny
Rogers man my parents would sit there
and belt out Kenny and it was wonderful
like it was Kenny Rogers uh didn't
intend this but because of him and his
art I got to see my parents as real
people you know not just a they're in
charge of me but real people with real
dreams and real thoughts and and
interacting with somebody else's art in
a way that like touch them and and and
touch them to the point where they
couldn't not [ __ ] sing along then
through the you use that [ __ ] like I
remember my old man I remember my mom
singing that to my father like you know
while my mom was making eggs and my dad
was like you know I'll put the plates
out and [ __ ] like that and in retrospect
you know cuz I'm now part of a couple
unhappen for a while that was like you
know pride like yeah we [ __ ] did look
at the [ __ ] we put together from scratch
man we got three kids they're all alive
and healthy and [ __ ] we're able to give
them breakfast you know life is good
even at work cuz it was the weekends he
hated [ __ ] work
but at least on Sunday didn't have to
work so like real joy I got to see my
parents as people all because Kenny
Rogers probably wanted to get laid isn't
that why everyone does anything like
I'll become singer man because I'm sure
I'll meet people and get laid and stuff
you know and you know money and and
whatever whatever reasons you know
people go for the entertainment life or
whatever or just to sing maybe that's
why I did it
it's that guy's fun I just want felt out
of tune I just wanna write songs I want
to say I want to tell [ __ ] they
decorated my life and stuff like that I
want to take him to islands in the
stream but because he did what he did
and went on his journey my journey was
made better with my parents so there you
go man was weird like a dude I never met
and it's not like you know I think about
Kenny Rogers all the time and stuff but
when I read that he was gone that's for
that's what came to mind all the good
times that he brought with him and stuff
you get one go around kids make it count
before I get out of here yeah yeah
Rosario we're gonna see a live-action
ahsoka man she'll like that's important
I'm sure people that work in the real
world and stuff and like politics and
government but like that's not [ __ ]
important but it is you know
that's kind of stuff that keeps going on
a regular basis inspiration not the
day-to-day of like you know
infrastructure and stuff like that and
that's that's awesome to have and boy
one you know really misses it in a
moment like this but we're all kind of
in the house but but you need the things
that make you happy then make you sing
while you're making breakfast for you
three [ __ ] brats in New Jersey and
[ __ ] like that you know
I just got back from church but they
were not unhappy people man they were
happy because Kenny Rogers was singing
they were singing along with him I never
met him but he decorated my life as a
Kenny Rogers lyric right there ah there
it is folks call someone you love today
let him know man that let him know how
much they mean to you I could I mean
it's not like I wish I'd called Kenny
and told him how much he meant to me
obviously I'd you know yeah I don't mean
it like that
but he did mean a bunch but there are
people in our lives that are not [ __ ]
you know famous singers that you can't
reach and stuff like that who you can
reach out to particularly now is we're
all isolated and whatnot lot of us you
know are lucky enough to be isolated
with some [ __ ] people so I'm not
going stir-crazy in here got a wife kid
in-laws live with me so you know there's
other people aren't plus I got look at
that [ __ ] dog Sergei me yes I got
shaky as well not everyone has somebody
to sit there and [ __ ] with and if
they don't chances are they may wind up
on the internet reading about some [ __ ]
falling down a rabbit hole that makes
them feel horrible and you know suddenly
this we're going through a worse time
than we really are because you're in a
[ __ ] quiet solo closed loop of
non-stop what was the news say now oh my
god more people died oh my god this is
happening oh my god lockdown
so you know think of those cats they're
by themselves they're just going through
this experience by themselves and stuff
reach out to the scats man give him a
shout chitchat with it'll take some time
and whatnot it's weird like when I was a
kid we all lived for the telephone like
you know [ __ ] you
be on the phone like we had a kitchen
phone and and my parents had a phone in
their room so you'd be on the kitchen
phone and like your parents be like get
off the phone you're still on the phone
you've been on the phone for like two
hours and now it's weird cuz like you
know I hate phone calls I'm like what
somebody's actually calling my phone
that's [ __ ] up
now's the time to actually throw that
away and make some phone calls reach out
to some cats you know and say a man how
you holding up during this thing it
ain't just about the physical health
sometimes it's about this and sometimes
it's about this yes it's gross I'm
wearing that written tour directed by
Kevin Smith's shirt but sometimes about
the head and sometimes about the heart
that [ __ ] has to get looked after to and
in time like this where people are alone
in the house and and sitting there and
going like you know what the [ __ ] what
is this gonna change and everything's
different mother if I will ever go out
again and [ __ ] I'm scared because you
know you just keep reading the news and
stuff it's nice to break that up with a
phone call that's just like hey man how
are you
isn't this [ __ ] up what are you doing
bah bah bah you know and and reminisce
you know now ain't no better time in the
world to sit around reminisce with an
old friend than right now remember the
[ __ ] good times remember you know
[ __ ] Kenny Rogers remember you know
[ __ ] you know two weeks ago when we
could do everything we used to be able
to do and stuff so some cats are
struggling ah like obviously I'm one of
them Here I am [ __ ] blabbing at the
internet you know about Kenny Rogers but
uh yeah some people need a little bit of
human contact now I mean this kind of
contact I mean the hey hey how are you
[Music]
alright Kenny Rogers man for some reason
I thought he'd live forever
some cats some cats make it thick like
[ __ ] they're gonna do it man they're
gonna beat the odds they're gonna make
it they're gonna live forever and Kenny
Rogers will live forever for sure man in
our hearts and in our minds sadly though
they took him out from the above the
ground part which bums me out
I'm telling you man like [ __ ] it's
weird when somebody passes and you think
about how much or how interwoven into
your DNA the DNA of your life not just
your creative DNA now you were living
DNA up day to day like ah listen the
song sums up my Spotify playlist but the
DNA of your creative life of your your
happiness the you know when you sing
generally you're happy even if you're
sad singing lifts your spirits a little
bit this guy was a singer and because of
that he encouraged other people sing
because it's infectious man got a good
tune and [ __ ] like that you know [ __ ]
what is more like you know when I was a
kid
[ __ ] would go [ __ ] apeshit
when YMCA played at a wedding or
something like that cuz oh my god
everybody could do that I can run out
there in [ __ ] YMCA and stuff and is
beautiful man like I remember being a
kid and noticing that and being like
well look at that a bunch of people who
normally act one other way are acting
this completely delightful way it's
because the music and the singing and
[ __ ] so that'll lift a [ __ ] spirit
man and it'll turn anybody you know good
song and a good crooning of it will turn
any one non singers and [ __ ] people
no voices or whatever the [ __ ] into
singers that was my oh man Kenny Rogers
of play and he'd sing my mom too she'd
be singing along man it's like Dottie
West went
Rogers would do Team ups with her and
and of course Dolly Parton as well and
then my parents would be rocking it like
you know he's doing Kenny and she's
doing dolly and [ __ ] then probably after
breakfast Grace and Dom are doing each
other [ __ ] hard you know like we
[ __ ] went to church we fed our kids
eggs
let's [ __ ] listen we're in the mood
because we've been listening to Kenny
Rogers let's [ __ ] go put the little
hook i latch on our bedroom door grace
and [ __ ] pound we did it we did it
we're children of the nineteen [ __ ]
80s and we got three kids of her own and
we're making it work in our tiny house
in New Jersey and we [ __ ] did it I
showed the kids on Instagram live this
last night but since we're talking about
my parents
I'm gonna share this [ __ ] with you this
as I was going through [ __ ] I mean here
look look around this [ __ ] room look
how [ __ ] where's that turnaround
thing alright look at all this clutter
you know I don't know if they still do
the show hoarders but I've been trying
to keep them the [ __ ] out of this house
for years because shaky because look at
all this [ __ ] there's some cool loot in
Chariton gave me this because working on
masters universe Tim's one of the
writers on the show and look at that
[ __ ] sexy Skeletor and [ __ ] any event
look at all this look at his power of
the duck [ __ ] all this clutter no one
will ever know that cuz the show's dead
now and this and excellent chair from
Greg Grunberg and all this crap I mean
the shelves are curated don't get me
wrong
that's my museum but there's a big naked
portrait of my wife but uh this clutter
man [ __ ] just unbelievable I don't
throw anything out and I act like
everything's important like I'm like
holy [ __ ] are you kidding me throw out
that septic pencil what if I cut myself
shaving
what are you kidding me throw out the
comics the mini comics that come with
you know every
Jay and Silent Bob joints Nucci boo
cheese snowgoons or I just save
everything man I can't help it I'm just
that way so this is was this a bill of
sale this is the bill of sale for my
parents house when they bought this
house 1966 the house I grew up in if you
watch me do this on his screen live last
night I'm sorry but since I was talking
about my parents and talking about that
house I grew up and I've got to share
this [ __ ] man it's crazy okay mmm here
we go man there's a closing statement on
my parents house the house I grew up in
integers of the me turn around so you
could read it
21 Jackson Street man that's where I
grew up this house was sold from the
Ackerman's WS door Ackerman to Donald
Smith and grace Virginia Smith comma his
wife I mean that would never stand today
for heaven's sakes like we're selling
the house to this man whose wife could
have a little piece of it too so anyway
that was a long time ago 19 let's see
the date on this [ __ ] March 25th 1966
that's four years in March April May
June July August four years of five
months before I enter the world that's
we're three four years no three years my
math could be wrong in any event this is
before I was born
that's how I get everything in life was
I'll I've done this before I was born so
here it is man look at it let me spin
this back price the house twelve
thousand five hundred men with five
dollars and seventy four cents in taxes
so the full price of the house that they
bought 12 505 man my parents put down
1,000 bucks and so they spent the next
20 years paying off 11,000
dollars men like I remember I remember
when they finally paid the house off
like I didn't understand these things
back then but my parents were like they
had the deed to the house and they were
like this is it
we [ __ ] own I guess not deeds bastard
wouldn't done it but something you know
the form that said this is [ __ ] how
much you own the house the day they paid
it off that gathered me and my brother
and my sister Virginian Donnell in a
living room and they were so like happy
and my parents weren't like this they
weren't I mean they were happy with them
but they weren't they weren't like you
know alright [ __ ] here's a thing that
you got to see in a lesson you got to
learn they were generally very you know
[ __ ] come cecum sod and stuff and
they did their things we did our things
and they were in charge of our lives
don't get me wrong but you know they
were never it wasn't like the Brady
Bunch
we ate together a lot my dad took me to
the movies and stuff and we were titan-2
family but remember the Brady Bunch
would have like sack races and the
[ __ ] in the backyard potato sacks or
they would [ __ ] like do very involve
[ __ ] you know we didn't quite do that
but one day my parents had come in here
they were so [ __ ] happy and proud and
I didn't understand I mean I understand
kinda they were like today we made our
last payment on this house we own this
house now mind you to a kid this was a
weird notion because I've been living in
it since I was a child and I'm suddenly
just told that we didn't own the house
but we did on it but like you know
[ __ ] mortgage and [ __ ] like that but
my parents were like we're alpha Munder
and they took a [ __ ] pack of matches
and they like it was crazy it's very
uncharacteristic of my parents they
wanted these type of people man but they
took our pack of matches and they lit
this [ __ ] forum on fire and the two
of them were so happy they were like
we're done we did it and [ __ ] you know
they paid off the eleven thousand
dollars plus all the interest or
whatever and they finally owned their
house it was crazy and and you know I
hear I'll be honest with you I don't
think I'll ever have that moment and
even if I pay off the [ __ ] house and
stuff I don't think I'll ever be like
Harley come here watch me burn this
document that was how [ __ ] rolled in
Jersey Sun so
how amazing is that look at this I mean
there's um packrat so I got a lot of
[ __ ] this is a fascinating little piece
of clipping that I've got from my mom
hear me put it down here and then I'll
show you what it is we were in the news
when we were kids well not not we
alright so there's a picture of my mom
very murky looking like the Loch Ness
monster Bigfoot photo very Furtick with
murky not because she looks like that
but because it's all muddled and there's
a car that we had smashed and there's
our fence or driveway fences down and
[ __ ] and the article says examining
damage it to 1976 Charger drives only
driven only 30,000 miles gray-smith as
my mother 21 Jackson Street Highlands
that's the house it explains the series
of circumstances which started November
24th when a pickup truck was stolen from
behind that maybe I should just not read
it that way was stolen from behind the
gangway restaurant Bay Avenue by two
local juveniles 14 and 16 at about 10:00
p.m. the pair apparently drove the
vehicle owned by Charles Wilson of Navis
Inc along Shrewsbury Avenue to Jackson
Street that's where we live hitting
gravel and a sewage pipe I remember they
were redoing the sewer the line at that
point
tearing up a fence of a summer residence
that's Pete king's house and ricocheting
across 21 Jackson Street plowing through
the fence on the Smith property and
damaging the car on the other side the
juveniles ran from the scene leaving the
vehicle with its engine running but
we're apprehended by patrolman Teddy
Jasper patrolman Eddie chambers man
there's a rock star names from my lives
my young life after they were involved
in another incident last week a stolen
van recovered an Aberdeen one year
was found with a knife and stolen credit
cards and also charged with possession
of these items one youth was remanded to
his parents custody [ __ ]
easy mom and dad gonna do him the other
was taking the juvenile defect detention
center in freehold pending action of the
juvenile authorities man so that's like
that's crazy this happened like years
ago let me see it doesn't list the year
because it was a 1976 Charger it
happened in them 24th but let me see
is there any date on the paper elsewhere
um no but I would want to say like 81 82
this app in 1981 1982 now vague memories
have awakened up in the morning be like
is there was there somebody happened in
our car in the driveway my mom being
like go to school so crazy shape you
fine man I'll show you some other [ __ ]
that I [ __ ] found like I said we save
everything look at this this is from
Newark newsman and it's February 12 19 I
can't see the date schecky talk about my
mother Grace Schultz is a PI aust
that was news man like this chicks
getting [ __ ] married and then then
there is this one and this is from the
Elizabeth Journal September 14 1964
schecky [ __ ] this is what I got they got
married but look it just says mrs.
Donald D Smith they just took her away
our identity and said look at her so
sexy I mean not to me that's my father
so cute so young so here is their
wedding announcement then look at this
[ __ ] this is what a [ __ ] slow news
life it used to be in the Irvington
Herald on I can't see that day October
3rd 1964 Donald Smith and bride home
from honeymoon that was [ __ ] news kids
and not just like an Aloha this is the
Irvington Herald and fog and it
newse enough that essentially the love
story behind the story is guy [ __ ] wife
in other place comes home comes a lot
they're newlyweds and then that's that's
why I save so many things because my
mother saved everything when I was
growing up and stuff for example this is
a ticket to go see trust how Hartley's
movie trust at the Angelika Film Center
and that happened I mean the writings
now faded on this Tuesday 810 1991 this
is a ticket from when clerks played at
the film fest Munchen the Munich Film
Festival I just save [ __ ] kids I just
save it this is a letter from George
Carlin hey Kevin okay you already had a
book but you didn't have one of these
[ __ ] best George Carlin and it
was it was a box set of all his albums
on CD what else can I show you here man
who you know what we can go through look
at this The Watchmen box when I got home
from you know people send you all sorts
of stuff and I don't see a lot of it
until I come home I was on the road for
like four months doing the Jay and
Silent Bob reboot Roadshow tour man so
believe that yeah so when I got home I
started unpacking things and I got to
see a lot of stuff so for example I was
showing the kids last night on the on a
histogram love look at this Jay and
solid Bob
smell my finger game you can get this on
Amazon right now man good [ __ ] times
I got a box of them we're gonna give
them away on the
exFAT man beyond if there's ever if
we're ever allowed to leave our houses
again here's another game Jay and Sabo a
big hard-on gay man's game where you you
know go like a man if you were Superman
and I was Batman who would wind [ __ ]
like that I got a box of these you can
get them right now on Amazon as
orderable is from the good folks of play
storm beautiful [ __ ] here what else can
I show you
mm-hmm this just again clutter see
clutter just boxes and boxes of clutter
clutter this is my fridge in my office
you can see all sorts of this is a
drawing that I did when I was a kid the
underwater city and in the midst of this
underwater city like you know was a
thing that you had to do where you were
like design a city the future we all
lived underwater and she blew this
[ __ ] he dead diver he's getting
fed on by sharks and here comes a
Portuguese man-of-war man there's a
basking shark he not to be afraid of
this is something my sister found see
that creepy guy that is let me see my
sister she lives in Vienna and one day
she was walking around with her husband
and she saw that in a store window me
and my brother had those in our room we
shared a bedroom at 21 Jackson Street
and we had those where that's where we
hung up our clothes like you know we
went to Catholic school and so we had a
uniform and [ __ ] like that and so you
hang up your sweater and your your tie
and your and your shirt and your slacks
all green except for the shirt that was
white and you hung that up and on that
guy so I've seen that [ __ ] since I was
a child and forgot about him completely
and then one day my sister sends me his
picture and it was like discovering a
long-lost sibling where I was like it
exists and so my sister sent that from
from Vienna I believe from Austria
um yeah man I'm telling you if you're
remotely a Kevin Smith fan this is the
room for you because if you were over my
house I'd be like go ahead take that
take it go ahead I got a bunch I got a
whole box of them here you want to see
something really cool something else I
found look at this these are called cush
cards man so it's a card comes with
pakka matches and you put a joint in
their joint goes right there so it
becomes a gift some of them like this
one is a Christmas card Merry Christmas
comes with a one-hitter you know so
basically you send them a card and it's
got one header in it or or you could
just use the space to put a joint note
how genius is that man and I got a box
like [ __ ] and there's the old jaws
game and there's Mushu how genius look
sometimes we're so busy moving forward
in life you know like I was on tour for
four months so busy like making stuff
that you don't really get a chance to
appreciate the stuff you made that's
that's the best possible problem to have
kids when you're like oh my god things
are going so well I can't concentrate on
the good things that are happening sadly
sometimes in life it's the other way
around here man let me show you some
artwork hangin up here so look at that
gigantic Batman statue man Excelsior
brick and then a brick from when we just
did the road show and that theater was
which theater was that the Paramount and
Huntington New York man big-ass Batman
statue from the sideshow folks
artwork there's Batman Suren are then up
there we got some gorgeous pieces some
artwork from the tours that me and Jay
have been on there is the iron Bob
helmet right there the only one and only
you know shelf of pictures and me and my
kid life and stuff
this I've had this since I was five
years old man is a mom dog with milking
pups and so he clicked the button and it
[ __ ] feeds the pups you see him go up
and down and stuff and then the mom like
barks and [ __ ]
once again I I cannot throw anything out
that was my senior athletic award for
basketball 1988 but I didn't play
basketball I merely videotaped there's
me playing hockey though that is
actually me and Frank Chanti but I I
earned that letter that high school
varsity letter by videotaping all the
varsity basketball games I was the
camera guy go figure
um the guy known for his cinematography
look at this a couple skateboards that
I'm gonna be hanging up soon here
spinning around and that one from Lulu
multi props gorgeous Chucky shut up you
better shut up Shecky this is the
outside world got the porch man and
there's a Runyon Canyon that's where I
go hiking all the time there's the dog
and how quiet it is world is so damn
quiet look at this JMU's and the hizzy
look at all those pictures of me and my
boy my best friend and child first child
there's my me and my actual child as she
ages through the years that's Kenny
let's say there's me and my dad and
Byron that's Jen's stepdad and there's
Harley baby early Gen the day we got
married
skali horse Akali Connell there's Jen
with Scully when she was a baby
there's us at IHOP the day we got
married that's where we had our
reception there's Jen holding bamm-bamm
who was in Jay and Silent Bob strike
back um what else can I show you man I'm
gonna move this box and I'll show you
the Mosier art simos got his own window
and stuff a bunch of artwork based on us
and smog because this is the room where
we record smut
one of my favorite things look at all
those brats see arms and [ __ ]
as my son dance acceptance letter over
there yeah Congrats you're in the
festival this is a big piece of dialogue
from clerks and French I've always loved
that poster man because it makes the
words the sexy you know what I'm saying
there's no picture of caste or anything
like that the idea of selling the movie
in France was these [ __ ] words and as
a writer that was everything to me
oh my god I loved it here's B's artwork
that Scottie Moser did when we were in
film school point that out all original
artwork by Scott Mosier Scott did Kevin
X it was called because I wore the Spike
Lee Malcolm X hat and Jersey all the
time so it says Kevin axe the Kevin X
protector of suburbia PPAs is post-party
at Spago's production that was the name
that me and Mosier came up with years
ago man there's there I am standing over
7-eleven also starring Scott Scott's
that this HD I was wearing my 40 acres
and a mule Jersey Catwoman is in it for
some reason
I hate humanity but I love ring-dings
really really [ __ ] awesome I wish I
could draw I've had that for this is
before we made clerks since we were in
high school out of high school since we
went to film school so from 1991 s from
1991 kids all right some people said hey
show me some of your comics I'll show
you the comics that I got here up top
that's a yoga hosers tusks shelf bunch
of mementos from that movie
then we get into some of those books
Aguila point book is fake obviously some
of those are props from movies cheery
a's that paper - toilet paper holder
came from you know tusk of course my kid
gave me this Baphomet Cup as a joke for
Christmas and stuff because you know
she's into like crystals and [ __ ] and I
was just like don't you know don't [ __ ]
with otherworldly [ __ ] you could let a
demon into this world and she was
looking at me like are you [ __ ] high
and I was like yes but that's that's not
why I'm saying this I'm saying this
because I was raised Catholic so now
whenever she gets a chance my kid gives
me [ __ ] Baphomet stuff see just a
token of my love
Harlequin was bafflement figure from
Slayer ma'am in a minute minute minute
ah so they look man all right let me
show you what else up there VHS is still
and then as bunch of trade paperbacks my
favorite trade paperbacks behind there
that's an original copy of clerks on VHS
it's Harley Morenstein from yoga hosers
buddy Christ plushie
here's more books if you could see past
as my weed strains snoogantay OG vu
cheese and berserker man all powered by
a good folks in caviar gold and stuff
look at that you see that face and trust
that weed there's the joint that the J
you know roll in or day the character in
Jay and Silent Bob reboot the Silent Bob
joint that they smoked props Brandon
made that for me this here's the Shelf
of the dead kids so there is I believe
this is yes skully molder and the
this one's Louie and this one's my dad
so you know when you when you die in my
life I capture you and I put you on the
[ __ ] shelf in a creepy supervillain
kind of way yeah
there's there's the dead folks man
parade of dead right there on my shelf
so I look over and see them every day so
I never forget speaking never forget
look at that gorgeous ring that fat man
ring I don't know if you could see
inside you see if I could hold it up but
it says to Kevin from there it is Stan
Lee Stan gave me this badass fat man
ring man can you believe that [ __ ]
there's my high school yearbooks and
whatnot as a bunch of hit girl that I
wrote is my book tough [ __ ] the other
books that I wrote some laserdiscs of
mine there's old scripts early editions
of clerks and stuff like that that's a
seat back from the Grand Ole Opry when
the whole man had forever and stuff he
loved the Grand Ole Opry here more
comics down there and then about the
third shelves we're like it's still
carrying that starts falling apart in
the last two shelves [ __ ] where I'm like
well I'll get around to that I'm gonna
get to that what I mean
[ __ ] did you see this look a tub of VHS
is that includes a box of Batman Returns
cars
what am I ever gonna get to that what am
I ever gonna when when will I ever come
on but there it is living hope time
despair here's an awesome [ __ ]
postcard of a scene from Empire Strikes
Back that replaces Lando with more stay
Oh EO EO his picture me emoji on top of
a roof quick stop
that was my design for the view askew
logo I drew that and I gave that to
Walter I can't draw for [ __ ] but Walter
animated it that's that was an
advertisement for the clerk's very first
screening clerks at 11:00 a.m.
over third theater three right there it
was my dad right next to the Infinity
Gauntlet so if it ever works snap back
my old man and be like you want to go
the movies actually I probably have them
you know much longer conversation with
them let me let me show you this [ __ ]
thing up here here on the museum shelf
these are all things that like very very
much me that's from my straight out my
childhood man
Snoopy stunt spectacular as my parents
wedding topper look at this gorgeous
[ __ ] Quickstop model that I got from
crazy for cult show man
those characters go to this McDonald's
playset which I loved as a kid I still
love today actually all this stuff
there's Pogo from the Okefenokee Swamp
weebles there's a Stanley Cup that me
and Brian and Walter and J used to play
NHL 96 well 94 through 96 and then you
know whoever won it got to hold on to it
for the year and stuff
this ain't the exact there's Country
Music Hall of Fame little ashtray from
old man clean hands Snoopy soap
dispenser this bowl is not the exact one
I grew up with but I [ __ ] this is my
favorite Bowl in the world I don't use
it but I mean when I was a kid I grew
the body I grew because I ate cereal out
of bull that deep man fill it all the
[ __ ] up and stuff long johns was a place
I used to work at not the one most
people know there's a Snoopy radio
there's a pop of my mom so I made a
homemade pop my mom this here man you
want to see something [ __ ] up
this is Starlog from and it's number 69
Nuge from April I want to save like 84
or something like that but let's let's
dive in let's dive into it shall we just
because I want to I want to share like
some [ __ ] with you
so this I of course I got expose you
Star Wars fan and [ __ ] like it's
Return of the Jedi and producer previews
but in it there's a story where is he
that captured my imagination when I was
a kid you see if I could find it yes
okay they spoke with Tom mankiewicz here
I'm gonna turn it on so you can see it
mind you is an old magazine okay
unveiling a secret identity Tom
mankiewicz he's the super screenwriter
who polished diamonds for James Bond
plotted an international flight plan for
Superman and penned the upcoming movie
heroics for the Batman now anybody knows
anything about the Batman movies knows
that Tom mankiewicz never wrote about no
movie that any of us saw but this was
going back to 1983 84 son and daughter
they they are talking about a Batman
movie we never got to see and a dark
serious version of a Batman movie that
we never got to see which is kind of
what they would wind up doing let's see
if this was 84 Batman June 23rd 1989
took five years later man but there's no
reference of Tim Burton listen to this
the Batman that screenwriter Tom
mankiewicz has in mind won't be a boy
scout and leotards cruising the city in
a souped up Lincoln his Caped Crusader
will prowl the gotham city streets at
night striking from the shadows and
silently and effectively as a rager as a
razor edge stiletto how awesome is that
I want the Batman's alpha to be truly
frightening states mankiewicz I hope we
could do something with his eyes so he
has penetrating and mesmerizing gaze
that will give him a Svengali look he
says referring to the famous fictional
hypnotist really when you look at the
Batman character he's only one step
removed from Charles Bronson in death
wish this is what they were saying in
nineteen [ __ ] 83 84 man
Batman project has occupied the
screenwriter for more than a year and he
as he tried to overcome its built-in
difficulties let's find out what those
were it has to has been very tough
Batman has no superpowers so I'm trying
to use the strengths he has as human
being to make him more human mankiewicz
says hopefully the movie can find its
own level as Superman did we're trying
to return to the original concept Batman
is a dark Avenger of the night
the villains while being outrageous will
be very cruel people and then the film I
hope will have its very own special type
of humor though it certainly won't be
the holy moley gee whiz stuff this was
the Batman movie that they were planning
by the beginning the Batman with a
starkly dramatic scene I hope we can do
the same thing our film opens with the
gunning down of Bruce Wayne's family in
the street now you know when you hear
that you're like of course it's an every
[ __ ] Batman movie but they've never
done that before and here they are
talking about that so I remember reading
this article and being like are you
serious like [ __ ] they're gonna do a
movie where Batman's parents get killed
and we get to see it like this
in the comics millionaire playboy Bruce
Wayne was sitting by his window and a
bat came by and he said to himself I've
got I'll be a bat to me that even
suggests stately Wayne Manor is in a
rotten neighborhood instead I have Wayne
roaming the streets at 4 a.m. and
witnessing another violent crime against
the family he captures his first real
criminal realizes his mission goes back
to his parents grave and then we're off
and running even the famed Batmobile
will get a facelift for the for the new
film though fans needn't fear seeing the
Caped Crusader tooling around town and a
black Chevette or dark blue Toyota over
the years they've given him everything
except a bat toothbrush mango which
truffle chuckles I like the Batmobile
though I think a new one should be
designed for the 80s an outrageous but
not ridiculous car whatever the auto
turns out to be it won't be seen in
daylight what I find ridiculous about
Batman says Tom mankiewicz in 1983-84 is
the guy walking down Fifth Avenue in
broad daylight and getting into a
Batmobile
I want a sleek powerful black card
that night by man who scares the willies
out of you day time is the enemy of the
Batman the Joker and perhaps the penguin
wait until you hear this oh my god I
remember reading this [ __ ] and being
like I just need to stay alive until
this happens the Joker and the penguin
encore has Batman's movie adversaries
although not in their familiar guises
from the mid-60s camp TV series The
Joker will dress in theatrical clothes
and still have green hair but he will
not be a buffoon there will be something
terribly scary about the guy Mankowitz
says the the movie reflects a return to
the characters original concept as
introduced by Bob Kane and Jerry
Robinson in 1940 the penguin lives in an
entire world of black and white and at
temperature about 16 degrees below what
everyone who everyone else considers
normal he won't be a rotonda little
fellow I see him as somebody much more
urbane and cold in every sense of the
word deadly they were on they were Tom
mankiewicz was on the future before the
future happened man let me tell you the
names though cuz there's one that's like
what the [ __ ]
here you go the Polygram film budgeted
at 25 million bucks will be produced by
john peters who did Superman well almost
did Superman lives ah
and Peter Guba who did the deep
executive producers are Benjamin Melanie
Carmichael oozlum Michael islem was
still involved even back then blah blah
blah here we go
ready for the cast list a well-known
director has been approached but his
identity cannot be disclosed at this
time also nothing is definite yet
regarding casting mankiewicz however
would prefer to see Jack Nicholson as
the chalk faced Joker that [ __ ]
happened and this blew my mind Peter
O'Toole as the penguin
David Niven as Alfred and in the
Christopher Reeve tradition an unknown
as Batman although no sequels are
planned according to mankiewicz it's
inevitable as my friend Robert Benton
said if 1941 had been a success there
would have been in 1942 so and look at
this little comic that they put in here
man because then you know there's no
Batman artwork but they leave this comic
they put in he goes pay no attention to
the and their distant relatives like Tim
fuller did this comic in 1983 and so
Batman TV's Batman is being pushed away
by hardcore Batman kids this was and
there's Tom mek'leth this was all before
it happened and that crazy look at the
table of contents man Anthony Daniels
interview this is a different simpler
time April 93 I keep saying 83 84 eighty
nineteen eighty-three you could have got
a Star Trek to Wrath of Khan video game
watch for heaven's sakes man let me turn
you back around hey look there's my
he-man lunchbox dr. greenthumb
in there there's my cutting boards and
stuff okay
how [ __ ] fascinating is that man
these cats were like [ __ ] thinking
about a Batman movie like that we
eventually got those kinds of Batman
movies man I love this I've held onto
this for [ __ ] years for that very
reason uh all right oh I was gonna show
you two Watchmen box so check this out
you know they they give you premiums all
the time
when shows begin still semi boxes they
like advertised the show and I guess
like you know if you like it you'll be
like holy [ __ ] look what I got on
Twitter or something like that I don't
know why they do it's expensive Spock
because the [ __ ] they send is very
expensive but I love when they do it and
stuff and most times we give it away at
fat man beyond when we do that show or
something like that so I'm gonna show
you the box that I got for the Watchmen
and I just found it you know when I was
cleaning out the office
trust me I mean I know you're looking
around going like clean but I was moving
[ __ ] around the off
and I found this amazing boxing
tournament so boom big box that's on top
of it like it's a really nice box made
of this okay so opening it up like it's
[ __ ] personalized man personalized
and there's a little note and the note
has that like gummy [ __ ] on it and you
open up the note and I was like who
loves me and it was this it's time and
it was just to advertise the premiere of
the watchman show so let's see what's in
the box
shall we we lift up and what do we find
watchman and watchman this is a mask oh
[ __ ] this will [ __ ] come in handy now
is that open look one of those so you
know you can [ __ ] walk around they
had no idea unless they knew that's
useful and then what else you got in
here
it's a watchman watch let's see it is
it's a watchman swatch it says tick tock
tick tock and there's a [ __ ] watch in
there how awesome um that's pretty sweet
now let's see what else the gun in my
back and my back I went away and it was
a watchman hoodie in that how awesome is
that man so there it is man that's the
watchman box and they were all the idea
is hey talk about the watchman which I
did without knowing I got a box because
I [ __ ] loved it man I just re-watched
the last episode two days ago and [ __ ]
does it hold up that is so damn good
alright folks there it is I've spent way
too much time
I meant to jump on here and do a test
run just to see how how YouTube lives
thing streaming was and it's pretty good
man and when we started you know it was
like 50 people and now it's 1.5 K 1
point 4 K oh oh we're losing people so
uh thank you for hanging out folks
before we get out of here I'll show you
one more what I think is a cool thing
this that's not it but that's my yo goes
there's poster and there's my Sundance
badge with it this is what I want to
show you for someone have to turn on
some lights to do it one this is like
family wall you know lots of pictures of
our combined family there's me as a kid
that's a picture we had in our least
rooms she was a baby
young Jen yummy yummy more family stuff
were big people all from Jen's big book
person look at this [ __ ] man for Harley
best Jim Lee when Jim Lee came and did
fat man on Batman he drew that while we
were just sitting there in that nuts
there's the elevator because the house
is a couple of floors and the kitchens
upstairs and here's a wall full of Mimi
Mimi look at the things I've done
Mimi baby as an original Walt Flanagan
artwork man from our widening gyre book
there's the green arrow ad for when I
was doing a save the Rio there's a
beautiful piece of rocky and bullwinkle
gorgeous weed artwork some awesome hit
girl stuff it's a SModcast piece comic
book men this is my
you know I'm in the Academy announcement
thing New York General Assembly one time
said something nice about me you know
gave me an assembly resolution thing
there's my honorary diploma from the VFS
which I am now there a creative
ambassador this was from when Red Bank
declared Kevin Smith they won Harvey
Award as Best new talent
that is my student council president
award because I was that as a stock
he was SKU stock Henry Hudson my alma
mater put me up on the wall there's the
thing my kid did when she was in arts
camp
I wanted to Jack Benny award at UCLA
I'm his key to the city that's from
Henry Hudson there's some pictures of me
I'm at the Warfield ladies the podium
down Paulsboro gave me a proclamation as
well
there's my diploma from Henry Hudson and
that it's congratulation for not having
to cop out on editorial pretty girl Zack
and Miri Make a Porno little trophy that
I got from Ethan noble artwork from you
know you know even in with Kevin Smith
there's me there's me and Mose shooting
the first thing we made in film school
called Mayday
there's me and Mose at kin in 1994
finding out we just won an award
there's me and Lois doing a press
conference for clerks from the mono Prix
in Paris a little department store
there's me and J with anis from Degrassi
there's an excellent Brody Bruce piece
of artwork cover and speaking of Brody
Bruce well look before Brody Bruce
there's Mike and certificates festival
they can clerks to festival do
and then here's another one
those three times one scam this is from
when I played
Connie Hall there Shecky trying to
[ __ ] get a thing she shouldn't try to
get a there's a big face of me there's a
big Chesley Prince of the kid and and me
and Jenny there's our chair backs from
reboot
there's our dogs this is where we
memorialize our dogs Shakey's like don't
put me up on that [ __ ] shelf you had
all the dogs have wind up on that shelf
are dead his big naked cleat Shields
sculpture of my wife that's me and and
Harley and her boyfriend Austin doing a
poster for a you know [ __ ] like you
better not [ __ ] if you know marry my
daughter type of movie and [ __ ] just
baby Yoda fan gave me that me and the
wife walking around is built like a
[ __ ] piece of artwork for one of the
evening with Kevin Smith three there's a
plus-one album that we did and we sold
the stash baby Bob's coat but this is
what I wanted to show you
whoa look at that man that's the
original Drew Struzan painting that
became the poster so Mallrats you can
see the brushstrokes should get in there
man
it's crazy that's the OG right there
that's us me and my friends painted by
the great Drew Struzan how amazing I'm
throw anything out kids and I guess I
didn't throw anything out for this
reason because now that we're all
trapped in the house I could take you
around and show you every [ __ ] thing
piece by piece
ah there it is man started as a Kenny
Rogers memorial show
schecky we're memorializing [ __ ] cat
mean they killed Kenny bastard um go
roll a [ __ ] Kenny Rogers song
that's what I'm gonna do my hang-up this
[ __ ] I'm gonna play through the years
and I'ma sing at the top of my lungs
like my old man used to on Saturdays and
Sundays when he was in his room she's
trying to be him and stuff like that
thank you for hanging out kids this fun
and therapeutic and chip let's do this
again real soon
me and Ralph are recording a Hollywood
babble-on
this afternoon at 1:00 maybe will stream
that in the meantime have a great
Saturday go out there and do some
weights stand and do something great all
right kids
hey stop this [ __ ] is it bad yes are you
sure you want us to stop streaming I
mean why do you have to introduce an
existential crisis right what I'm trying
to wrap up the video I'm not sure of
anything you kidding me I'm still
learning [ __ ] mate [ __ ] 40 MB 50 in
August and I'm still I don't even I'm
still learning how the plumbing works
and [ __ ] in any event thanks for hanging
out everybody through the years you
decorated my life we're all just islands
in the stream you got to know when to
hold them no end for them no end walkway
know when to run you never count your
money when you sitting at the table
there'll be time enough cow and when's
that when the dealin's done